puntos contra la desigualdad y la
discriminación es el lema de la
quincuagésima segunda asamblea general
de la Organización de Estados Americanos
oea un evento regional que sin embargo
no escapó a la realidad de la guerra en
Ucrania en una reunión previa al inicio
de la sesión el presidente ucraniano
bolodimir selensky intervino e hizo un
llamado a las naciones de la oea En
búsqueda de apoyo
en qué lado estaría Simón Bolívar en una
guerra como esta que Rusia desató contra
Ucrania
A quién podría apoyar San Martín
entrados en materia el secretario
general del organismo Luis almagro hizo
un llamado para que la democracia sea la
única opción en el Continente debemos
tenerlo presente y trabajar para a
través del diálogo la necesidad de la
Democracia de la paz encontrar las
soluciones que nos permitan vivir en
unas Américas donde la democracia sea la
regla sin excepción solo democracia para
todos los habitantes de las Américas Y
es que cuando de democracia se trata las
miradas encuestas en un caso
problemático el de Nicaragua el país
centroamericano se retiró en abril de la
organización tras la condena de los
países miembros que declararon ilegítima
en las elecciones donde fue reelegido
Daniel Ortega el presidente de la cidh
abogó por la liberación de presos
políticos
provisionales respecto de Nicaragua la
última las últimas se adoptaron ayer
respecto de 45 personas que están
privadas de su libertad de la corte
dispuso supuesta en libertad inmediata
la atención se centra también en torno a
la crisis de seguridad que vivió Haití
la asamblea que se extenderá hasta el 7
de octubre contará con la participación
del secretario de estado de Estados
Unidos Anthony blinken quien arribó a
Perú como última parada de su gira
suramericana que también lo llevó a
Colombia y chile